These lanky insects are called assassin bugs
– and rightfully so
They ambush their dinner by
sneaking up on spiders in their own webs
The assassin bug often slices through strands
to take the most direct path to its prey,
but scientists were stumped
Now, a new study reveals how assassin bugs
limit telltale vibrations
Assassin bugs slowly grasp strands of web
with their foretarsi,
carefully pull them away from each other
until they break,
Then they gently release the ends to minimize
any vibrations the spider might feel
Researchers used laser vibrometry to measure
the vibrations caused by this maneuver,
and they were virtually undetectable—
revealing how these bugs earned their name